in a debate with commission president
vonda lyon
members reiterated their support for a
common eu vaccine strategy
but raised concerns about delays and
lack of transparency
the eu has so far finalized six
contracts with pharmaceutical companies
parliament approved the eu's recovery
and resilience facility
which will provide countries with
financial support to mitigate the impact
of the kovic 19 crisis
at least 37 of the funds should go
towards climate and biodiversity
projects
a moscow court sentenced russian
opposition leader alexei navalny to
three and a half years in jail
meps debated russia's crackdown on
protesters with eu foreign policy chief
joseph morrell many of them also
criticized his recent trip to the
country
one in six workers in the eu earns a low
wage
leaving them less able to cope with
economic crises
members called for an adequate minimum
wage to put an end to in-work poverty
and reduce
inequality
last year parliament backed the
temporary suspension of the use it or
lose it rule on takeoff or landing slots
for airlines
for the 2021 season parliament agreed
carriers should use at least
50 of their slots instead of the usual
80 percent